valero
montréal ont aujourd'hui non pas pour
parler de la naissance du royal bibi qui
arrivait ya pas très longtemps mais pour
par les technologies ça vous vous en
douterez aujourd'hui c'est un événement
qui a réalisé par un qualcomm
on va parler des always connected pc on
va parler des pc qui sont tout le temps
connecté un peu amer de votre smartphone
l'idée très simple très court votre
smartphone vous amusez pas à les peindre
tous les jours comme vous le feriez avec
un pc si vous faites part de votre pc
attention c'est un peu l'idée donc ce
qu'on fait c'est que bien on va se faire
un petit tour de l'ombre on va aller
voir ce qui se passe tout près du coin
comme et puis on va en profiter parce
que l on s'écroule il pleut pas plutôt
bonne nouvelle je dirais qu'il pleuvait
pas c'était sans compter sur le temps
londonien qui est toujours assez
incertain c'est un peu paumé pour tout
vous dire des sept espèces dénombre tour
derrière ce très drôle parce qu'alors
vous avez vraiment ce mélange
d'architecturé entre à côté un peu
préservé côté très moderne des espèces
d'immeubles des années 70 soit 9,4 selon
la norme française
c'est un mélange de tout
c'est assez marrant et puis derrière
vous allez la tamise donc le spot est
assez cool
[Musique]
oh
bon arrivé j'ai trouvé j'ai rendez vous
ici face aux côtes il enveloppe soleau
[Musique]
la plantation vient d'avoir lieu c'est
vraiment intéressante parle un peu de
l'univers du pc devoir un peu sur quoi
on pas dans l'univers du pc
alors là je me suis mis dehors j'adore
ce spot est vachement bon sauf qu'ici il
pleut une espèce de petite bruine un peu
pas terrible qui va pas faire du bien
mais n'apparaît donc ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on va aller faire un
petit tour de table on va se poser je
vais vous montrer il nous devons passer
pour tester nouvelle le nouveau pc de
lenovo c'est la yoga c'est 630 c'est
justement ça on est dans l'idée dé
always connected pc au lou reed the
runaways cognitive je vais à l'hôtel mon
pote je vous explique exactement ce que
leur dit vous allez voir en quoi c'est
vachement intéressant c'est
révolutionnaire parce que on se retrouve
avec des pc qui sont à mi chemin entre
l'univers du smartphone et l'univers du
pc
ok
[Musique]
donc là on est arrivé dans l'hôtel anton
by hilton plutôt pas mal situé plein
coeur de londres c'est vachement gamme
alors justement aujourd'hui je me rends
compte que j'ai fait une connerie tout
de suite là je suis arrivé à londres et
j'ai complètement oublié de prendre mon
de réflecteurs secteur pour brancher mon
ordi pour le charger c'est un peu
compliqué donc je vais devoir sortir de
toute façon je vais vous emmener avec
moi regarder là où je suis là mais
vachement bien on est quand même bien
bien bien en place dans l'ombre alors je
connais pas trop trop la ville à chaque
fois que je viens c'est pour des petits
sauts de puce ça a l'air pas mal mais ce
que j'adorais regarder là là vous avez
un petit quartier résidentiel tout
autour là vous avez des espèces de
grandes tours un peu de tous les côtés
c'est très marrant à londres comme tous
les genres se mélangent vers l'est sur
pas mal avec leur petite maison une
petite baraque
j'ai récupéré du matos a testé quatre
autres travers ces nouveaux la nouvelle
yoga sur dix est de lenovo
sellal yoga c'est j'ai mangé le terme
ces 630 g avec un plein documentation
plein de trucs à lire comme ça je vais
être au top sur geste la dragonne et 850
il est vachement vachement cool et
justement on va lui faire un tour en
extérieur on va profiter un petit peu de
la ville est la plus aride honteux c'est
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
on va aller se balader et je vais vous
parler des baissés always zone all ways
connected pour voir un peu ce que c est
quoi ça correspond ce qu'on peut faire
avec et en quoi ce truc là même si on
s'en rend pas compte quand même
relativement révolutionnaire
[Musique]
regardez je vous en laisse devant le
palais de westminster on est pas mal qui
a big ben qui est sous cloche peut pas
en faire grand chose c'est un peu
dommage bon alors je voulais justement
vous parler aujourd'hui de ce qu'on
appelle le always connected pc et le
always on alors ça veut dire deux choses
la toute première que ça veut dire c'est
le always zone saviez votre pc en gros
il est tout le temps en lui mais à la
manière d'un smartphone
c'est vraiment là dessus qu'on voit
c'est à dire que comme vous allumez
votre smartphone tant qu'il aide la
recharge temps qu'il est chargé et tout
en lui mais en gros vous appuyez sur le
bouton salué en l'espèce de veille mais
sa lutte au sommet a contrario sur un pc
actuel si vous voulez vraiment en tirer
le meilleur parti un moment il faut
l'éteindre pour le rallumer ça prend un
certain temps c'est pénible c'est si
c'est ça justement cette nouvelle
génération pc vient remédier à ce
problème donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
le always ensuite vous avez le always
connected pc ça ça veut dire quoi ça
servirait que votre pc en fait comme
votre smartphone il est tout le temps
connecté à internet ont fait un truc est
vraiment vraiment même pas intéressant
parce que de la même manière que votre
smartphone est tout le temps connecté à
internet en gros en tâche de fond il
venir récupérer en permanence vos emails
des quelqu'un vous contacter sur un
réseau social vous aurez notification
c'est exactement la musique votre pc en
gros votre pc il ait jamais atteint
il est toujours un peu allumé et ça
c'est vraiment intéressant
pour arriver à des résultats pour
pouvoir utiliser notre pc comme un
smartphone il nous faut derrière de la
puissance de la performance
et c'est là que qualcomm intervient avec
notamment le qualcomm snapdragon 850
toujours la fameuse gamme 800 chez
qualcomm qui permet d'avoir plus de
puissance plus d'autonomie d'aller plus
vite en connectivité est justement
l'idée c'est d'avoir une meilleure
connectivité globale avec votre machine
parce que on peut imaginer plein de
choses blanka d'usagé l'heure ça on en
reparlera peut plus tard parce qu'il y
aura plein de choses à dire là dessus
mais ce qu'il faut vraiment comprendre
c'est que votre machine
elle est tout le temps connecté en
permanence j'ai parlé il ya pas
longtemps justement de la 5g
ça va être encore plus l'orangé dans les
années à venir avec des machines qui
sont tout le temps inter connectées les
unes entre les autres que ce soit une
monde connecté que ce soit les voitures
qui communiquent entre elles afin plein
de choses plein d'objets en gros le tout
connecté
j'en ai déjà parlé d'ailleurs si vous
n'avez pas vu la vidéo sur la 5g je vous
invite à y d'abord parce que je fais un
tour assez exhaustif et s'est permis un
petit peu d'entre apercevoir ce qui peut
arriver et on voit qu'avec ce fameux pc
always connected
on va toujours dans l'idée de la
connectivité cette fois ci avec un pc
donc meilleure autonomie meilleure
performance de l'intelligence
artificielle toujours optimisée sur
petit musée derrière
[Musique]
bouter les une solution comme ça c'est
pas facile il faut juste avoir des
petites cartes sim avec un abonnement
data comme vous avez sur votre
abonnement de smartphones vous pouvez
très bien il va gêner récupérer une
deuxième carte liés à votre data de
smartphones comme ça vous le mettez donc
et quel que soit l'endroit où vous êtes
vous allez avoir en votre pc qui est
connecté le truc est vachement bien
parce que normalement quand vous balader
par exemple eh bien vous allez chercher
une connexion wifi pour brancher votre
pc c'est souvent la galère la plus
besoin vous avez votre ordi vous avez
vos dates à vous avez votre carte sim
est vachement bien et si vous avez
l'itinérance à l'étranger c'est encore
mieux comme ça vous pouvez bosser de
n'importe où et c'est justement ça a
coûté connectés en permanence parce que
vous avez accès à vos emails vous avez
accès à vos data vault à niveau tout ce
que vous voulez internet votre
ordinateur jawad a été très facilement
comme votre smartphone vous pouvez
l'emmener partout avec vous vous avez
une très grosse autonomie c'est ça qui
est vraiment dire avec ce système de
pessac et tout le temps connecté avec
cette nouvelle techno avec ce nouveau
processeur de qualcomm notamment le
cendre agon 850 vous le faire mais vous
mettez dans votre sac à dos vous le
prenez vous trouverez vous êtes connecté
ça monte de nouveau 10 h et c'est ça qui
est vraiment intéressant ça que je
trouve vraiment vraiment cool parce que
on se dirait mais quel besoin je dis
pourquoi ce que j'aime bien ce truc là
au final si on devait réfléchir on a
plus de besoins que ce qu'on pourrait
penser parce qu'en fait en ordinateurs
actuels après c'est un peu standard un
pc portable c'est assez contraignant si
vous voulez qui marche correctement vous
devez les tailles l'allumé attend d'eux
qu'ils se chargent récupérer vos emails
enfin c'est une vraie galère là par
contre vous et tout le temps connecté en
permanence pakula vous souhaitez quand
vous avez besoin c'est plus la machine
qui vous contraint c'est vous qui
choisissez qui vous l'utiliser à bon
escient
quand vous avez besoin mais c'est ça que
je trouve en tout cas vraiment
intéressant est vraiment révolutionnaire
dans l'idée spa ou ce que vous en pensez
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous êtes assez
d'accord est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est un usage qui est nouveau un usage
qui est intéressant est ce que vous
voyez l'intérêt pour moi très clairement
la cible sur des personnes pour des
besoins de connexion évidente vous avez
besoin pour bosser vous êtes dans un
train dans un avion pas vous ressentez
vous êtes au bureau vous êtes chez vous
vous connecter facilement de partout
c'est un peu pénible de le faire depuis
votre smartphone ou alors vous avez pas
les utilisant un smartphone vous avez
dans votre ordinateur vous avez qu'à
l'ouvrir vous en voyez vous êtes
connecté c'est pratique et sans vous
poser la question du partage de
relations depuis votre smartphone ou
votre ordinateur qui rajoute une étape
de plus
en gros on enlève des étapes on
simplifie on va plus vite plus loin
mieux connecté avec une plus grosse
autonomie enfin c'est que des bénéfices
en plus des trucs est vachement bien
avec cette techno c'est que ça nous
permet d'avoir des pc qui sont assez
compact la voyez par exemple vous
présente la la nouvelle yoga 632 lenovo
et c'est franchement un truc qui est
tout léger tout fins pratiques à
transporter alors bon la lenovo vous
connaissez un ils ont des machines qui
font vraiment de yoga tout l'intérêt de
la gamme yoga avec cette famille alors
celle là on va tester dans quelques
temps dont vous invite dès maintenant
vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
mais ce qui est vraiment cool avec cette
typologie de machines c'est que on a
vraiment des ordis qui sont un peu aller
aussi épais qu'une tablette on peut
connecter facilement comme un smartphone
kiosque est très léger qui prend pas de
place qui est très facile à promener
emmener partout avec soi et je trouve
que c'est vraiment intéressant et
d'autant plus qu'avec une machine qui
fait cette taille là vous avez une
grosse autonomie bien évidemment là je
vous parle de nouveau mais il n'y a pas
qu'à nouveau il y aussi pas notre marque
il ya vu s'il ya samsung et hp
il ya beaucoup fabricant de sa typologie
de pc les pc qui sont toujours connectés
toujours allumée et je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant c'est un marché qui
va se développer de plus en plus un
modèle pour tous qui va être bureautique
professionnelle d'ailleurs plaint de
plein de nouveaux produits c'est
vraiment hyper content vous invite à me
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas juste
en bas en commentaire on va papa pas là
à la nand en commentaire mais continue
petit tour de mon mieux ce soir on a un
petit repas avec la team qui étaient
présentes de qualcomm la team press
quelques journalistes ont fait un truc
assez sympa et après direction le dodo
vous embrasse et puis je vous dis à très
bientôt